[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
good evening my friends and welcome to
the best of piers morgan uncensored for
the very final time you lucky people
with me jeremy calmer piers of course is
back monday just in time to sink his
teeth into the new prime minister and
his or her cabinet and it was with our
dearly departing leader that we start
tonight's show
so what is boris johnson's legacy talk
to his political educate mccann is here
along with former labour mp luciano
virgil ah kate i start with you um
what is boris johnson's legacy from a
political analyst like yourself um i
sort of think politics will never be as
fun again but on a serious note is there
a legacy or was it tarnished beyond
repair
well i think the big worry for boris
johnson and you can see it a little bit
in his last couple of weeks in office is
that he's not quite sure what his legacy
is going to be i mean covert 19 made it
really difficult for him to achieve some
of those things he talked about on the
steps of downing street and look you
heard from people there really mixed bag
but people have strong opinions about
him and about what he achieved he set
out to do something that was quite
unique he managed to harness votes from
a group of people in the country that
very rarely come the conservatives way
and the thing that always sticks in my
mind about boris johnson is the night
after he won that election he came back
and he said look i know that i've
essentially borrowed your votes and i
know that i need to deliver for you or
you will never vote for my party again
he understood the implications of it and
the pressure on him and i think for him
he will be frustrated and probably a
little bit sad that he's not been able
to deliver fully on the things that he
pledged and that would have been cost of
living it would have been so called
leveling up now we've seen some of that
in new railways we've seen some of that
in new money but even there there have
been accusations that perhaps it's not
gone as far as it should have perhaps
it's been a little bit hollow and it may
well not change the lives of people in
the way that he wants it to so jeremy
what will it be
boris johnson wants it to be the green
agenda now and ukraine i think
potentially ukraine may stick in a lot
of people's minds
listen um
a huge uh critic of boris johnson we'll
talk more about how you left your party
the man that johnson uh defeated in 2019
anybody could have defeated jeremy
corbyn though couldn't they to be fair
um i mean it was it was
all but uh
foregone conclusion that um
certainly at that election that boris
johnson and the conservatives were going
to win and boris did so off the back of
saying he was going to get right but i
mean that's an interesting one i've said
this to kate before privately i mean i'm
not a marketing guru or or a political
analyst but i remember the night 2019
election really clearly the liberal
democrats said we're not going to do
what the british people the majority of
the british people want the labour party
said we haven't got a clue what we're
going to do and all he had to say was
get brexit done
that was done covered very very quickly
i always use this example and i'm going
to throw this at you straight away i had
somebody on the radio today and i can't
swear so i won't but he basically said
boris johnson is a lying whatever but he
is my lying whatever now this man
despite his flaws despite the lack of
attention to detail his rather shady
relationship with the truth that we all
know
still to this day resonates with the
british people and we talk to fair none
of us would be surprised if he didn't
make a comeback well i think it
resonates with some
british people and but certainly his
popularity has decreased significantly
since when he first came into office and
you know the gap in the polls now is the
greatest that it's ever been so yes that
was certainly the case when he when he
came in in 2019 that is not the case now
and we have to look at his record and
what he is what do you remember him for
um and what he hasn't done to see why
that is the case and i think you know in
my mind he's brought the office of being
a prime minister into disrepute i mean
you know when else in our history have
we seen what we've seen just looking at
what happened with party gate for
example what do you say to the people i
bring kate in as well what do you say to
the people across europe and the world
who are in complete
i don't know confusion that we got rid
of a democratically elected prime
minister who won a a massive majority in
2019 because he had a piece of cake what
do you say to that but it was it was
more than just a piece of a cake and it
was a
you can call it just a piece of cake it
was many pieces of cake it wasn't just
one piece of cake it was many people
enjoying the cake and what is what it
symbolized to the british people who i
think have a very strong sense of
justice and fairness at a time when
people had to make massive massive
sacrifices people were not allowed to
mourn people not allowed to go you know
not allowed to be with their families
and their friends not allowed to
associate and here who was a man who's
behind closed doors behind the gates of
uh downing street was having parties
with you know living at large when
people couldn't yeah enjoy those those
things that we normally take for granted
and it was it was a sense of injustice i
think an offense that people to but you
know it wasn't just a piece of cake i
think that's a really interesting way to
describe it okay a sense of injustice
and yet during this ridiculous
long-winded tory leadership thing that's
gone on for about seven years it seems
and we have a new prime minister on
monday we'll talk about that in a sec
frighteningly to think that 70-something
percent of the conservative membership
if his name was on the ballot would
still be voting for boris johnson so has
his popularity gone
well i think this has a lot to do with
the difference between how the
conservative party in the country so
conservative members and the
conservative party in westminster feel
they don't necessarily feel the same way
not about what they want out of a leader
and certainly not about their own prime
minister about boris johnson now that's
been the case for a while and there are
some in the tory party who've recognized
that and have tried to bring the two
closer together and fix it but they
haven't succeeded and that's a
fundamental problem for whoever gets
into number 10 next it's probably going
to be list trust because the party has
got used to this idea of chaos and
remember there's a whole new load of mps
who came in in 2019 who were not wedded
to the conservative party structure they
are not bound by a sense of duty or by
any sense really that they have to wait
their turn for a ministerial job they
feel emboldened and emboldened by
winning in seats where the party never
won before and crucially they feel like
that's down to them and that's given
them the freedom to act out if you like
and behave in a different way and that
split between the party in the country
and the party in westminster is
problematic that's very true luciana
also one of the things that i hear
repeatedly from from from tories is is
not about his behavior far more
traditional right-wing tory voters
complain that he didn't deliver the tory
manifesto that the traditional tory
things lowering taxes he was hell bent
on a green agenda he seemed to
concentrate on things that aren't
traditional tory voters now kate's
absolutely right the tory party is in
turmoil we have sunna called trust every
poll points to liz trust becoming the
prime minister on monday uh sunak will
not accept a job because she'll offer
him something that's not good enough
what becomes of the tory party because i
guess your ex-employers the labour party
should be rubbing their hands with glee
but i still find it astonishing by the
way that they're only 13 points in front
they should be out of sight shouldn't
they by now well it was 15 points
i call into the you go and i salute you
for walking out on that lot because
corbin was an absolute disgrace
genuinely yeah and and i it was every
good reason why i left the labour party
back uh in february of 2019. and
i mean just to answer your question i
think part of the challenge is that
on what he pledged
boris johnson did not deliver
on so many fronts
you know you touched on like leveling up
you don't have to look at the most
recent gcse results to see the disparity
between the you know the north and the
south whether it was all the hospitals
that he said he was going to you know be
building that's gone to the wayside the
festival of brexit which you find out
today they cost millions of pounds uh
and again in delivering it there's a
litany of things that you know he did
pledge and if you make a promise an
election manifesto you have to
who do you fear most trust or sunni well
it's going to be mistrust like every
pole points in that we're not allowed to
say that because we have to do straight
down the line but every poll says it
will be liz trust she's the continuity
candidate isn't she they have both
continuity candidates they both sat
around the cabinets i don't understand i
did you know kate i'll bring you into
this you lot of political you know
you're you're high high flyers i don't i
think the tory a party is a really
strange beast right they waited months
for somebody to be courageous enough to
stand up and basically with the greatest
respect stick a blade between boris
johnson's shoulder blades but whoever
did that was never going to be trust and
that comes out and every hustings and it
comes out in every poll when he resigns
sooner right having supported all these
things that people disagree with it
folded like a deck of cards didn't it
and he would never be trusted by the
traditional tourists so i i think i
think the labour party what do you make
of the labour party under kierstarma
then i think it's the labor party making
massive strides to first of all actually
come up with kind of proper plans you
know what we've heard from the labour
party just in the last few weeks a plan
which we should have had from this
government we should have had from boris
johnson in his last few weeks we should
have had parliament yeah i mean that you
know in advance of the off-gem um paris
cap the energy price cap rising um as it
did at the end of last week and what we
have at least from a party a party of
opposition under the leadership of
secure staff would you rejoin them is it
probably thought of i'm not allowed to
rejoin no but in two years time would
you rejoin him with kia stammer in
charge instead of that anti-semite
jeremy corbyn um let's see what happens
in two years time it's it's you know
it's uh it's academic for this moment in
time um okay quick question um we know
about monday the queen is not going to
receive her new prime minister uh 15th
prime minister in buckingham palace
going to be in balmoral um
the priorities for the new prime
minister i mean who'd want the job this
country is broken the energy crisis the
cost everything i mean it's a it's a
pretty hard task isn't it forever takes
over
it's going to be a mammoth task and the
most difficult thing for liz trust if it
is liz trust and as you say the polls
point in that direction is that she has
spent the last however many weeks making
quite significant promises to the
conservative party members which have
been heard by the rest of the country
and she may well find it difficult to
deliver on
hardly any of them because of the scale
of what she's going to have to do she's
going to have to tackle energy prices
that will be her first major
intervention but there's also food
prices inflation and remember every
decision she makes could potentially
fuel inflation some people saying some
experts saying it could be 22 by next
year everything feeds everything else if
you help for example those at the lower
end with energy bills but not those in
the middle classes who maybe could get
through it well they might stop spending
they might stop going out to pubs and
restaurants stop spending on clothes and
we know those businesses are really
struggling too the government can't help
everyone trust has been clear about that
but essentially that's what she's going
to be asked to do and she's going to
have to find a way to navigate that
alongside everything else including the
ukraine and that very quickly is what i
find astonishing because sunak if you
strip it down is a more traditional tory
in terms of he's talking about prudence
and he's saying we can't make promises
and we can't do that and yet they're
seemingly going for that continuity
candidate but this speaks speaks again
to what we've seen from the
conservatives over the last 12 years
because that's how long they've been in
office but you know we are in this
crisis at this moment in time i was a
former shadow energy minister for three
years between 2010 and 2013. and we
didn't as a country do what we should
have done to save for when it rains yeah
we're in this absolute crisis now
because we have this over reliance on
foreign imported gas we haven't seen the
investment we should have had in nuclear
we're an island we've got wind that
blows we've got tidal power which we're
using solar the whole thing
we could be powering millions of homes
we could have done so much to interact
with properties across the uk we've got
some of the most leaky properties across
europe we could have
seen millions of people not spending
money which just escapes through their
door and that's why we're in such a dire
situation now with you know we're facing
inflation
listen it's it's we've done this every
single night and i say to both of you
we've done it every single night about
broken britain and the cost of living
crisis and you get to a point where you
feel what more can we say people are are
struggling and and it's not just those
on on lower incomes they talk about the
jams every single night they're just
about managing people who pay all their
bills and do all that and are struggling
hard hard times but eating episode the
head of adf said come january 50 of
households in this country boris said
buy a kettle what no we'll be spending
more than 10 or more of our disposable
income on our energy bills this is not
just about
technology i agree imagine opening your
doors to ukrainian refugee only for them
to walk out of those doors with your
partner about three weeks later we'll
meet the woman who did just that should
tell us the whole story it's here it's
after the break we're coming right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh welcome back to uncensored my friends
now they say no good deed goes
unpunished and one woman who would say
he meant to that is lorna garnet back in
may lorna and partner tony welcomed
sophia karkadim a 22 year old it worker
as a refugee from ukraine and whilst
lorna was no doubt hoping the addition
of the household would settle in nicely
she wasn't expecting her to settle into
the bed next to a partner and the father
of her kids um
this this scheme by the way 25 000
british people signed up for the homes
for ukraine scheme and in total 84 000
ukrainians
moved into hosts uh houses 350 pounds a
month um
first up lorna thank you so so much for
joining us really really appreciate it
um
i don't know where to start
um
just tell us the story whilst i asked
the people in the gallery to turn my ear
out because i can hear them all asking
what they're gonna have for dinner uh
lorna
tell me how it happened
yeah
um so basically um
anthony was adamant that we moved in a
ukrainian refugee to help obviously
everything that's going on in the war
it's horrendous
so he pleaded with me to go on his side
to help bring in
a ukrainian refugee into our home so i
accepted
and ten days later um she's packed her
bags and gone and he's followed behind
her
can i just go back to when you said he
convinced me were you against the idea
was his motivation humanitarian or do
you think his motivation was different
i'm not trying to foresee what was gonna
happen but i'm just wondering you you
painted the picture that he was keener
than you why
he well
he
he wanted me to accept it because of
what's happened in his past with his
family he because he's told me a
background story that he
he's got russian blood basically and his
granddad were rushing
and they fled the cold war so he wanted
to do something good
and obviously if it would happen in our
country then
he'd like to think that someone would be
there to help us but i was i wasn't dead
against it
but i had my worries about it because
obviously we've got a three-year-old and
six-year-old together and bringing a
stranger into our home around two young
girls i was really funny about it
it's really interesting to from from
afar to have watched uh you know the
people in the united kingdom show such
tenacity i think and and do that so i
think it shows an awful lot about our
country but yours is one of the the most
talked about stories because as you said
within 10 days
not i mean fast by 10 days what did you
start to suspect what what happened i
mean 10 days is nothing
it isn't so it was literally day two of
her being here she arrived on the
wednesday by the thursday her appearance
changed
so
she'd gone from wearing baggy clothes to
hair scrunched up to them wearing more
look up tops plastering her face with
makeup
and
she would always be the first one to
welcome in him
home when he'd walk through the door
saying oh anthony you're home you're
home
um i've made tea and i'd be a bit like
well i've already made him tea do you
know
but she'd always kind of like drag him
in she's always been the first one there
to welcome him so that were a bit of a
red flag at first but obviously i
couldn't bring it up with either of them
because
it wasn't such a major concern at that
point
how quickly do you now know they got
together
from even before her arriving
even before
i'm out in the press yeah
yes it's come out he's put in the in one
article i think it's with the sun
and that he'd been talking to a four
month prior
to her arriving in the uk
so
in this scheme that involves 84 000
ukrainians
is there a whiff of the fact that this
bloke
knew and somehow managed to get her to
move in with you guys was this
pre-planned in any way is that how you
now feel
i 100
100 i think it was all done over
facebook of a messenger and he used the
government scheme to help bring her here
oh my lord um one of the things that's
come out obviously recently is is that
a lot of these families who showed such
desire to help and get their 350 pounds
that's not enough i think uh the
refugees minister lord harrington has
called for the money payment to be more
to maybe be doubled because of the
rising cost of living you talk very
honestly about how you believe that he
was doing it out of the kindness of his
heart and then you paint a picture of a
bloke who'd got this planned how does it
leave you feeling because this is the
bit of the story that i really struggle
with because you say
i don't i have no ill will towards him
really or her
i haven't
basically what's done is done
um
but in the grand scheme of things 350
pound wouldn't have helped at all
because the set up cost obviously with
buying her toiletries feminine products
going out shopping to go buy a new
clothes because she came with very very
little
um i've spent
a hell of a lot more than 350 pounds
but but but i'm not i'm not trying to
listen i respect you but i mean you said
i'm looking back i'm happier than i've
ever been so you weren't happy with him
anyway i am so you weren't happy with
him anyway it was more
i was happy with him it's his past um so
three year ago he cheated on me
with his boss from work
we have to become so they will never
that we can't when we've got that
together we can't be specific on that
because obviously there's only one side
but i will say this to you um you say
that you hold no ill will and and that
actually this is extraordinary thing
about you is that you say that you still
support the scheme despite that the
heartache it's brought to you yeah
i do because the way i see it is you
can't tarnish everyone with the same
brush there's good and bad in everybody
out there
and
unluckily for me we picked
a bad egg
you say a bad egg i do believe that this
is gone
so i do believe that there's so many
genuine genuine people out there who do
need a roof over their head they do need
the support just to get back on their
feet to find a home to find themselves a
job and live as a normal human being
should i think you're an amazing woman
in an interview with yorkshire live your
ex-partner said uh the couple that's him
and his ukrainian lady are moving to
ukraine to help orphan children all very
admirable what about his own kids
exactly exactly this is my issue at the
minute
in reality some radio station i've never
heard of i was doing the right thing
that i believed i was doing to help
someone that was fleeing a war zone
i was making her feel comfortable silly
things like puffing oh put puffing
pudding ukrainian subter it's all very
it's all right but i do i do have to ask
you this because it isn't the public
domain you say you hold no ill will to
her and i really appreciate you coming
on and no will wilton but you've got a
restraining order against him
i have yes
due to threatening messages
so that has to be put in place i'll tell
you something i've spoken to a few
people in my time lorna and i have to
say that you are extraordinarily calm
and and and and maybe is it is a lesson
for us all actually that whatever we
think is happening at the time when you
take stock
you realize that things weren't great
and maybe all of this however painful
puts you in a better place but what i
really admire about you genuinely is
that you can still which is i think it's
quite a british thing i'll be slagged
off for saying that but i thought the
way that the british you know people
rallied behind this desire to help
ukraine ukrainians quite rightly was
amazing and you're still sat here saying
i'd do it again which um
which must mean an awful lot to people
watching because it means a lot to me um
i wish you luck moving forward and and i
really um with the kids as well they're
okay and i hope that tony finds
happiness with whatever she's called
sophia um thank you so much lorna i
really appreciate it lorna garnet there
the lady who opened her doors to a
ukrainian refugee and literally 10 days
later he ran off with her what a
balanced and wonderful lady thank you
right next to an uncensored toddler in a
tiara in the week when we should have
been focusing on princess diana and her
incredible legacy 25 years on princess
pinocchio has managed to yet again steal
the headlines with another set of truths
when will it ever end we're back in
three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
now it surely cannot be a coincidence
with morgan as safely a sconce on his
luxury yacht but meghan markle has
decided to produce some of her finest
work i reckon she does it to wind him up
you know morgan's on holiday let's make
the old man choke on his fresh oysters
on a serious note in the week when we
should all be focusing on princess diana
and her incredible legacy 25 years on
the global media instead reporting megan
comparing her marriage it's unbelievable
to nelson mandela's release from jail
now today mandela's own grandson slammed
markle for equating the culmination of
nearly 350 years of struggle with the
celebration of her wedding and if that
wouldn't have got morgan heaving
overboard this afternoon this is just
ridiculous a new episode of megan's
podcast archetypes dropped with special
great guest mariah carey here's a teaser
with a warning hope you're not in the
middle of your dinner
if there's any time in my life that it's
been more focused on my race it's only
once i started dating my husband then i
started to understand what it was like
to be treated like a black woman because
up until then i had been treated like a
mixed woman
i'm now joined by royal commentator and
biographer angela levin talk tv
commentator afia hagen and royal expert
from the u.s kinsey scofield ladies
welcome um
let's start with my friend angela levin
is it me or the majority of the british
people that are wrong what is this woman
up to what is her motivation for
continually it seems drawing attention
to herself whilst kicking the very
institution that that has been
long before her and will last long after
i don't i don't get it
well i think it's quite simple actually
and it's not just the uk
it's happening all around the world of
people who are seeing right through her
i think her aim is to get rid of the
british royal family without a doubt
and part of that is because she has to
win
she fights and fights and goes on and on
until she wins wins what well she wins
her battle she didn't think she was well
treated there in fact what it was of
course was that she wasn't used to it
you can't change your country change
your family change your job come into
something that's very unusual and decide
within five minutes you want to make
them modern and they should listen to
you and she should be number one they
should make her very very famous and
concentrate on all her beauty and her
brain and all the rest of it
without giving anything a chance if she
stayed there it might have been helpful
and and been sensible and fitted in but
she won't because she wants everything
her way all the time um if i could bring
in kinsey schofield from america thank
you so much for joining us kinsey um the
americans are famous for loving the
royal family and i don't even know i did
that accent um just explain to me when
when this i mean the new york post today
toddler and tiara has made it pretty
clear what they think of this woman
are american people's views of her
changing are they supportive because
today she's played the race card again
i do think that they've changed because
america is really struggling right now
with inflation gas prices politics i
mean everything is so polarizing so when
meghan markle sitting in her mansion
goes on tv to complain about the you
know becoming a princess and having all
of this attention and this platform
given to her by her in-laws i do think
that perception is changing in america
and we're a little bit more critical of
her after the oprah interview we all
sympathized with her we wanted to take
them in we wanted to protect them but we
talked about that a year ago there's no
reason to continue on with that story
what does she have to say what is what
are her morals what are her values and
what are her objectives we need more
from megan than continuing to obsess
over the past i completely agree i fear
hagen um i know that you see it
differently i appreciate you being on
the show what i don't get about meghan
markle is are we saying that she didn't
realize what she was marrying into she
seems very
uh to me to to be dead set on this
course of destroying in her mind the
royal family she seems to have a very
high opinion of herself and and if you
as angela said you judge the global
reaction to this
there's real anger
real anger i think that's faux anger to
be honest i think actually
what angela said was right she wasn't
used to it absolutely she's changed jobs
she's just got married she's had these
huge life changes uh marrying into the
royal family it was a huge thing for her
but she always wanted that she always
wanted that she was outside buckingham
palace eyeing up the royal family years
and years ago do you not go with the
people who say she had this completely
laid out this is a plan to get with this
boy who's had all sorts of issues and
has as we all know had problems right i
mean prince harry right now in the
united i mean i i was watching something
today they were saying these two should
be stripped of their titles and and sent
away how can you still trade on
something that you spend almost every
day slagging off that's what i don't get
look meghan markle is talking about her
experiences when you talk about playing
the race card that's unfair because
there is no such thing as playing the
race card she as a mixed-race woman is
talking about her experiences which
affects her every day unfortunately you
can't choose that so it's not playing a
role right okay we know each other no no
no no no no it's about talking about her
it's about her experience kinsley
finished so i'm going to finish as well
it's about talking about her experiences
as
you asked do i think that she planned
every moment of this no i don't i don't
i really really don't think she alright
she has that much free time who do you
think there's a lot of people who spend
a lot of time reading between the lines
where there is nothing to read she gave
an interview
and headlines were extrapolated from
that that's nonsense to say that she's
been absolutely ghastly her time has
been totally inappropriate when harry's
grandfather was dying in hospital and
she knew and harry knew they'd been told
she had two weeks or three weeks to live
she still went and talked on oprah
winfrey's show that is disgraceful to
upset him and upset the queen well what
her father was doing i agree so let me
you say i said about the race thing and
if there is any form of racism you know
me we've known each other a long time in
any part of the world disgusting and
wrong but here's what i get
she's that upper own i'm sorry i'm going
to say it backside she has the temerity
to say that my wedding to a prince and i
take kinsey's view in the middle of a
global economic recession where families
are struggling she says and i quote me
getting married i was told it was as
important as nelson mandela his grandson
today says who the hell does she think
she is come on that's again we also need
to talk about the way this feature was
written and the way that a lot of these
quotes have been done angela i let you
finish so i'm going to finish as well a
lot of these quotes have been
extrapolated for their own kind of
generating their headlines what she said
was a cast member of the lion king said
to her
she is not comparing herself to nelson
mandela i mention it
why mention it member of the lion king
said to her that this moment in time was
like that she's not comparing herself to
nelson mandela
if you read the next line it says she
knows that she's known nelson mandela
okay let's bring in she's not let's
bring healthy
let's bring kinsey back in from the u.s
desperate to speak kenzie oh i'm so
sorry i but i i just have to stress
meghan markle is a savvy woman she has
gone through press training she's gone
through royal press training this is a
woman that knows how important sound
bites are the writer even acknowledges
that she speaks as if there's a bachelor
producer living in her head she knows
what these reporters are going to take
away and turn into headlines she knows
the talking points and quite frankly she
is so important in the united states
that she could say this is off limits
and this is off limits megan knows
exactly what she's saying and what she's
doing i think the woman is very
intelligent so i think it's silly for us
to say oh she had no idea that people
were going to pull certain headlines she
is very skilled and very savvy and was
probably some pr guru in another life
i'm conniving well can i just say all of
us would agree and this is what really
winds me up of fear right
tomorrow is 25 years
since the princess diana died okay the
tragedy that rocked the world right her
two sons left without a mother you
cannot convince me we could sit here all
night and say that yet again meghan
markle's timing don't tell me it's a
coincidence she wants the world to be
talking about her instead of diana
that's her problem that is it she sees
herself as diana number two she sees
herself as an alternative donna she
wears diana's perfume when she was with
harry she was saying that all sorts of
things that she's very close to diana
harry said he thought his mother would
they would be best friends i mean she's
planning herself to be another diana
because she thinks she's like her
because she also felt that she was um
treated badly of course she wasn't it
was a whole different sort of i would
love to know and she and she loved the
royal family but she couldn't help with
it i would love to know a fear yeah you
can but can i just say this i would love
to know what diana princess of wales
would have made
michael i agree with you yes sofia
you're sure i can answer no thanks
angela you know i think it's really
disappointing actually that this has all
happened around this time because i
would love to be talking to you more
about diana's legacy about 25 years
since she passed about where we all were
when it happened yeah about you know she
was a fashion icon she was an icon of
philanthropy yeah about the legacy she
leaves yeah
why has it happened because meghan
markle has let it out now and you cannot
affair with the greatest of respect
she is savvy kinsey's right she knows
what she's doing she has released this
the cut and that ridiculous podcast to
have imagine millions she's paid for
that on the eve of the death of his
mother and i am astounded that prince
harry does not have a pair big enough to
say i love that was my mother come on
but you've got no courage to say
anything against her he will lie because
um he doesn't want to upset her she will
just let her do everything and she's
made a total wreck of him i spent a year
and a quarter with him hang on the
second if i if you could i spent a year
and a quarter with him and he's totally
changed
he's just become resentful and
aggressive and he's he's taught him how
to hate his family he got on very well
with prince charles they had their
problems earlier on later on they were
very compatible and she's just destroyed
him and i think he's up a terrible
terrible situation at the moment at the
end of the day he's a grown man she's a
grown woman they're a married couple i'm
pretty sure that they had discussions
around the timing of the release of the
podcast
next time i'm censored now it was 25
years since the death of the people's
princess diana the question is will
meghan markle ever be able to replace
her in people's hearts
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
25 years ago today diana died sadly the
whole world in mourning one word that in
your mind would sign up diana
oh she was amazing personally you know
she did the job
and uh that's all they have to say
should
feature cardinals but incredible human
brilliant and i was on my way to work
and i just read the papers and i said it
can't be true
and it was a shock i thought she was the
most wonderful princess she was
beautiful lady i met her and i was in
awe of her i thought she was
amazing what do you think the people's
princess would have said to her son or
meghan markle about what's going on
i think she would have preferred case
because i think kate's lovely
and she's really kind and nice i think
megan's a little bit in it for herself
and what do you think diana would have
made in marco what would she have said
[Music]
you go on girl
what word would you describe meghan
markle as oh
do we have to don't like her
one word that sums up meghan markle
i
i feel for her to be honest yeah i do
yeah i just think that
it's just been really hard on her and i
i agree with harry i agree with their
decisions and their choices i think it
was the right thing to do to get her out
there before
history like he said started to repeat
himself
so a cross-section of opinion joining me
now is talk radios royals correspondent
rupert bell uh princess diana's friend
sally morgan who worked with her for
nearly five years in the 90s and lawyer
paula rhone adrian ladies and rupert uh
welcome sally can i start with you um
i found it really strange i live in
windsor i i went up to the castle today
to just gauge opinion and i almost found
this generational
reaction if i'm honest the older
generation
called a beautiful wonderful
inspirational and caring
and have no time for meghan markle the
younger generation would say to me we
don't really know too much except for
what we've watched on the crown but we
feel sorry for megan
who was diana the woman that you knew
what made her so special in your mind
well i think that she was um she and she
turned out to be very outspoken
she uh she was
one of the first people to
talk about her mental health and mental
health she was one of the first
prominent people to embrace individuals
with aids
she was somebody that stood up for the
underdog and i also think that people
could see
her pain
i certainly could see it and i saw it on
a daily basis
was she inspirational i think she was i
mean she was inspiration for so many
people for for so many women at that
time that were having difficulties in
their marriage in their relationships
you know if the princess of wales can
divorce the prince of wales if that can
happen then i can certainly leave my
husband who isn't treating me too well
or is having an affair so i think that
she was an inspiration to many people um
paula to bring you in um
meghan markle has by anybody's standards
um
caused
so much reaction and let's be honest a
lot of it negative you could feel that
today on the streets you read it almost
every day i think she's caused a
negative reaction i do think
that the press have reacted negatively
my problem my problem with that and i
said it last night and the reason we're
doing it is because it is it is
everywhere it's what people want to talk
about here's what i'm going to say and
i'll say it again if you don't want to
be in the royal family
because you don't want the press
exposure and you don't like every facet
of your life being
interrogated i get that you go to
california with the love of your life
and you have two children you don't land
and sign a deal with spotify and this is
the bit that really gets on my bits if
i'm being completely honest every single
time there is something that matters to
the royal family like the death of
prince philip like you know today the
25th anniversary what does old meghan
markle do drop her latest truth bomb
it's a podcast it's true her timing is
dreadful paul yeah no i think it is i
think that ah you know listen dave this
is what happens the negativity just runs
right what's the fact i'm going to say a
negative i'm going to jump on the
bandwagon and say a negative when we
talk about facts i think what we're
missing here is a reality
you described diana so beautifully and i
would say that i could describe megan in
exactly the same way well we could
describe i could describe megan in that
way but if you look and forget what
she's done to the royal family it's not
what she's done to the royal
family remembers that she don't think
she
has i don't i don't know her what i do
know is that the message the very clear
message that we are getting reported to
us is that she's a bully that she's
aggressive that she's taken over harry's
life as if he's some weak individual and
yet we forget that his own mother was
forced to flee this country she herself
was planning to move to la she herself
had decided to begin a relationship with
somebody who didn't look like her who
didn't talk like her who didn't come
from a family that fit into the
establishment and this is what you're
asking of megan she wasn't prepared for
this and neither were the establishment
the establishment got it wrong with
diana they got it wrong with andrew
let me bring in let me bring in let me
bring in rupert bell if i can talk to
the israel correspondent he shared a god
daughter with diana and knows through
his family his brother trains for the
queen many links coal stream guards as
well rupert you're very you know you you
always play it very straight down the
line what did you respect what was your
response to what i said about meghan
markle like her or loather it seems to
me that she drops this stuff at the
exact moment to cause as much
embarrassment and hurt to the royal
family as possible
it does her timing is horrendous and but
she has created this we when we went to
the wedding the groundswell of public
opinion was so much in her favor
and yet she has managed and to end up
basically painting this picture that
everything is everybody else's fault
it's never her fault
and i think that's part of the problem
it always seems to saying
that
ex-member of the royal family has done
this that member of the reform role has
done that she has not done anything
wrong and i think that's what's
frustrating people
why does she always feel the need to pay
the victim as she sits in her 14 million
dollar villa in in california when most
of us can't you know worried about
whether they're going to get food on the
table so i really do think she needs to
start reading the room and realize that
what she is saying most of the time
doesn't
resonate with most of the british public
paula that's quite an interesting point
of rupert's how would you respond to
that quite easily we talk about this
groundswell as if we can dictate what
others think i don't know what the
society thinks because it's not being
reported what i'm being told is that
that's what people think but your own
report has just informed us that
actually there's a lot of people out
there who have sympathy for yeah
absolutely and i said i suspect i
started by saying it was generational i
genuinely believe that absolutely um and
i wonder if it's because of where people
are getting their information from and
if it is generational which i think is
probably right um there is the younger
generation that get their information
get their news from other places
absolutely the older generation who get
their news from different places and who
trust where they get their news i'm not
doubting that but you haven't answered
the question and a supporter of fear
hagan of her last night also did not
answer the question do you not think
there is something in the fact in my
opinion there is we're all entitled
opinion that every time prince philip
died today is the 25th anniversary of
diana the queen is ill she keeps
dropping this stuff via third and fourth
parties there's got to be i'm not saying
she might have a case i'm not saying it
wasn't hard i'm not saying that there
have been people who have said and done
things massively unfair to her i
absolutely can see the comparisons but i
absolutely when i look at those pictures
of the two of them in the uh the diana
picture in the black polar neck and her
as well diana looks vulnerable lost
scared meghan markle looks straight down
the camera and looks like i've got this
absolutely licked i don't she she
doesn't create sympathy in me that's the
problem and and let me tell you why
because let me answer the question
because you answered the question
yourself but your tone was very quiet
when you did i noticed that
you said that the bombs are dropped by
some third or fourth party person omar
schmidt or something we're not
suggesting are we that this is megan
that is putting out this information
well we know that it is
and then secondly even if she did deny
it where are we going to read that why
do you forgive them
with me on this
bizarre article that came out in and i
think it was 2021 forgive me if i've got
the date wrong where it referenced but
in very in lots of detail about the
approach that is taken in relation to
megan as opposed to the approach that is
taken to lovely is that because of the
color of her skin seriously i don't know
you tell me i'm interested in what you
say to that i mean she will tell you yes
archetypes yesterday you heard the
podcast she said that she felt that she
was treated as a as a black woman only
when she married her prince um and
that's of course in any way if that's
right that's fundamentally wrong i've
said that from day one i just can't
sally get away from i'm just being
honest i can't see rupert makes a really
really good point how does that look and
sound right now with this country on the
precipice of economic disaster
absolutely but i do think that when you
look at megan and you look at how she is
the one that really is controlling harry
there's absolutely no doubt she is i
mean no she is paula harris
and utterly in love with her when you
really really love someone you will do
anything for them she recognizes that
she refused she looked at the system she
refused to bow to
her brother-in-law and her sister-in-law
she could not understand that i'll tell
you what i want to bring on i want to
bring rupert back in because i like the
three of you to to answer this next
question rupert
what would diana the people's princess
and let's be honest floored let's be
honest with her ex-husband both used the
media systematically my old man worked
for the queen mother and he said that
everybody after the queen has used the
media what would diana have have said
about megan when i was out and about
today at windsor castle half of the
people were saying she'd have taken her
under the wing she'd have felt sorry for
the other half was saying she would have
been gutted that her son and her brother
and his brother had split up over this
woman and she had taken action what
would you say rupert
i i think she would have tried to give
megan all the advice and would have
probably been around to actually
explain the pitfalls that are likely to
come her way and realize what joining
the firm is all about
now i don't know whether they were
briefed enough but the dutch
meghan markle said that she wasn't
briefed which he knew all about it when
you go in and are going to be
a member of the royal family it's pretty
it comes out pretty quickly and i think
that's what she would have done she
would have and she would have had plenty
of experience good bad indifferent
whatever to bring to the table because
she remember she came to the royal
family as a 19 year old very
inexperienced young lady a big age gap
between her and our husband whereas
megan was a a lady of the world being an
actress being out there already married
before so much more experienced
that's it from me stop cheering you
lucky people five weeks covering for the
big man of course piers morgan back
monday at eight just in time to sink his
teeth into the new prime minister just
remember whatever you're up to this
weekend make sure it's uncensored and
for the final time tara
[Music]
i'm tommy dunn and this is talk tv the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i have no idea what he
did is he went over one of more
movements is going to launch a nuclear
strike on north korea or even a shark
pit that i then fall into turned out he
pressed it right at the end
and then walked a butler with a tray
carrying a dark hood
here's the diet coke
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm nadira tudor the vote
count is underway to find out who will
replace boris johnson as prime minister
his trust and rishi sunak have spent the
last six weeks battling and vying for
every last tory member's vote the new
leader will be announced on monday
russian energy giant gas prom will not
resume gas supplies to europe on
saturday as planned blaming an oil leak
it comes after g7 ministers announce a
price cap on russian oil exports to curb
revenue financing the war in ukraine and
to tackle inflation in the west and the
queen won't attend the highland games on
saturday it's understood her majesty is
suffering from mobility issues on
tuesday she'll swear in the next prime
minister from balmoral for the first
time
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i